adopte un chat abandonné c'était le
message ce week-end dans cette
animalerie de maurepas l'association
family wanted spécialistes dans le
sauvetage des chats mis en place un
stand avec 22 animaux une opération qui
a attiré de nombreux curieux
on n'a peut-être pas toujours là la
démarche d'aller en association pour
pour pour adopter d'avoir des chats
c'est plus intéressant de riadh obtenez
chaque ont été abandonnées
comme moi comme ça ils ont ravi les
visiteurs ont pu observer et caresser
les petites boules de poils pour lancer
deux jours il ya des coups de coeur il
ya des coups de coeur qu'on n'a pas sur
papier ou sur un site et qu'on l'a quand
on voit le chat quand le chat plan de
ses yeux dans les yeux et se passe parmi
les félins rencontrer on retrouve orphée
un chat veulent à vos données de moins
d'un an
donc elle voit pas du tout des deux yeux
mais elle se repère dans l'espace comme
si elle est vraiment très agile très
habile on souhaiterait pourrait lui
l'adoption dans un appartement il
faudrait pas qu'elle sorte pour sa
sécurité
de préférence dans un foyer calme et
patient voilà c'est pas trop de deux
cris de bruit orphée n'a pas été
abandonnée ce week-end la mia retrouver
une famille quelques jours plus tard au
total cette opération aura permis à
trets chat d'être placé dans un nouveau
foyer
d'autres sont toujours en attente d'une
nouvelle maison leur fiche leurs photos
sont à retrouver sur le site internet de
l'association